après les francofolies de la rochelle
les vieilles charrues de carhaix deux
cent mille personnes sont attendues
jusqu'à dimanche soir un festival pour
tous les publics rock même au delà eric
cornet alexandre dupont ils sont arrivés
hier des quatre coins de la bretagne
parti pour 4 jours de vieilles charrues
monté il ya 17 ans par une poignée
d'étudiants
le festival a su créer un sillon
singulier au coeur de l'été rock
les premières scènes presque 100%
bretonne des débuts ont laissé
progressivement la place à du lourd
place au rock et à sa tête d'affiche
rendez-vous désormais incontournable
pour un public de connaisseurs
en effet d'état festival en mouvement
qui apporte des innovations toujours
pour rossi pour accueillir les
festivaliers dans les meilleures
conditions par exemple qui ne vaut
niveau de ces espaces scéniques et on
essaye d'être toujours des toujours un
peu à la pointe entre guillemets pour
pour que ce festival ne tourne pas en
rond ne rompent pas
en tirons garantie avec les anglais de
motörhead groupe mythique survivants de
l'âge d'or du métal 30 ans d'existence
des hordes de fidèles et une puissance
de feu presque intacte
mais vraiment content d'être là j'aime
jouer dans les festivals parce que nous
nous mélangions avec d'autres styles et
pas seulement du heavy métal ou du hard
c'est un bon mélange
on vous attend
mélange des genres et côté public
quelques effets secondaires parfois même
surprenant
certains restent de marbre les autres
savoure
autorités on te prends tu mettre de
bâton fracassé réguler quoi enfin son
premier monte aux reds au baptême
motorrad
dans la foulée c'est ben harper qui a
offert hier soir un de ses moments de
grâce coffre souvent les vieilles
charrues
ce soir on remet ça christophe maé ou zz
top au programme pour un nouveau mélange
des genres
une belle ambiance jeu